what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard undata
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is going to be another video in
my r tutorial series
and for those of you who've been
watching some of the earlier ones you
know that i've been working through
a variety of packages from the tidy
verse and this is going to be another
one of those videos
so today we're going to tackle the
string r package
which is going to be a package for
attacking all of your character
and string and regular expression needs
so in this tutorial we're going to walk
through how you work with character
vectors and strings
we're going to talk about subsetting and
replacing components of strings
and we're going to talk all about
regular expressions now just a few notes
before we get started
first of all please take half a second
of your time to smash the like button
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
also if you guys would be willing to
support me over on patreon
i will have a link to that in the
description of this video and it would
mean the world to me
as always with these scripts they're
going to be available on my github repo
also in this video's description now
keep in mind
as is the case with a number of my r
tutorials
they are somewhat adapted from or at the
very least
uh quite heavily influenced by the book
r for data science by hadley wickham and
garrett grolomand
i do highly recommend checking that book
out
there will be a link provided for that
book now
like any other tidy verse package
i highly recommend getting acquainted
with the cheat sheet
that's going to be linked and then i'll
also provide a link to a
uh awesome tutorial for string r which
is available on the tidy first website
so now without further ado let's get
started
all right so by default in r if you're
creating some object
and you put double quotes or single
quotes on the outside
r is going to default to creating a
character string
now in this tutorial keep in mind i'm
going to use these terms
character or string or sometimes even
character string
fairly interchangeably but just keep in
mind i'm referring to the exact same
thing
now if you want to create a string
but you want to have a quote on the
inside that's the one instance in which
you want to be careful
and use double quotes on the outside and
a single quote
when you're referencing that quote on
the inside
so let's see some examples of this i'm
going to run this chunk of code
and then i'm going to have string one
which is just
this is a string no problem there string
two has double quotes on the outside
and then a single quote for this quote
that's on the inside
and if i just expand this that looks
just fine when it comes back here
but when i did the single quotes on the
outside and the double quotes on the
inside
it comes back looking a little weird see
we've got these backslashes going on on
the outside
you probably don't want that so just be
careful when you
uh set these up if you plan to output
these
now if you concatenate these different
elements
you're going to create what's known as a
character vector so
for instance i want to create a vector
called numbers
i'm going to concatenate these elements
1
2 and 3. now let me just
bring this back out here i have a
character vector
we run the structure of that it's a
character vector of size three
the elements are one two and three
they're all individual character strings
concatenated into a character vector
now rather than having these separate
elements say one
two and three we may want to merge these
different text elements
into one single one so that's where
either the paste
or str underscore c functions are gonna
come in handy
now paste is a function from base r
and str underscore c comes from string r
they do the exact same thing but i do
just recommend getting used to str
underscore c
just to get used to the string r family
of functions that all begin with this
prefix str so
the str underscore c function or paste
they're gonna have the different
arguments sep or collapse
sep standing for uh separator
and the difference between these is
they're both
going to separate these elements
by whatever you choose the difference is
whether we want the separator to be
between the elements
or within the elements so let's see an
example
now i've created these two of vectors
shameless plugs one and shameless plugs
too
subscribe to richard on data and smash
the like button
check out the other r tutorials and
julia tutorials as well
yes i'm terrible you don't need to tell
me in the comments section
so let's see what happens when we bring
shameless plugs 1 and shameless plugs 2
together
using this uh argument sep equals uh
comma followed by a space it's going to
do
pairwise subscribe to richard on data
comma and smash the like button
bring that into one vector and then next
the next pairwise combination check out
the other r2r tutorials
comma space and julia tutorials as well
so we took this comma this then
this comma this separated them into two
vectors
now let's compare what happens with
collapse we run that
and we've got subscribe to richter on
data and smash the like button
no separation between them whatsoever
but
we took the comma and the space
thereafter
to come uh between these two things
which are all coming together
so naturally we want the best of both
worlds we want
a sep just to be a uh space here and
then the collapse to be
comma followed by space and we've got
subscribe to richie on data and smash
the like button
comma space check out the other r
tutorials and julia tutorials as well
now i got to be honest sometimes i have
a challenging time just remembering the
difference between the two off the top
of my head
it's nothing though that some uh good
old trial and error won't
uh help you get through lastly maybe you
want to return
the length of your string that's a
common operator that happens and gets
passed to a function where you're doing
something more complex
so we're going to return the length of
shameless plugs one
let's do that and we've got 26 and 31
for
uh subscribe to richard on data and
check out the other r tutorials
respectively
so not much to that next thing we're
going to cover is subsetting and
replacing strings
and that's where uh the str underscore
sub
function is going to be really helpful
so i'm going to create a new
uh string here just call it shameless
plug that's subscribe to richie on data
and now we can do this either forwards
or backwards
so if i do str underscore sub for
shameless plug i've got one and nine
well these two arguments will tell us
just where to select from
one to nine will just give us the first
through ninth
characters let's just subscribe here
because it's a nine letter word
but then if i put negative numbers here
i'm gonna work backwards
so i'm gonna start at the 13th to last
character and go to the
last character and i just get richer on
data so
very very useful operator here you may
be interested in changing the cases of
your strings
that is going from uppercase to
lowercase or vice versa
and luckily we have functions for that
we've got str to upper
and str to lower so let's just see an
example
if we run the str to upper function on
shameless plug
we have the super enthusiastic looking
subscribe to richard on data
well this can be used as an intermediary
as well
let's see an example of that and you'll
see what i mean by this
so let's suppose the very first letter
of shameless plug
so that is this s here
i can use str underscore sub to take the
first letter there
just go one to one that just gives us
the first letter
and now we're going to assign that to
the function
str to lower on the outside of str
underscore sub shameless plug one one we
do that
and look at that we've successfully
changed that very first letter
from a capital s to a lowercase s
awesome now last thing i want to show
you is the str
replace function that's a much
more general way of going about doing
things like that
we're just going to find a pattern and
create a replacement for it
so i'm going to create this obvious
statement here
i like pi and then under str replace
we've got two arguments pattern and
replacement
we want to replace as our pattern like
with the replacement
love we do that and bam we're gonna
return
i love pi that's simple enough right
that shouldn't be any problem
next up let's talk about regular
expressions
but before we even get into that string
r gives us a helper function
str underscore sort just for arranging
in alphabetical order
a string so i'm gonna create a string
with
even more shameless plugs like subscribe
and comment notice that that is out of
alphabetical order
but i'm just gonna run uh str underscore
sort
and then we go c is before l which is
before s
it's in alphabetical order now
the str underscore view function which
is up next here
is going to provide us a view based on
some match that we want to create
so let's say that we just feed to it
um the even more shameless plugs string
here
uh with an s on quotations
so this is case sensitive and notice
this view that comes back to us
is going to highlight this s over here
okay but we can get we can get a little
bit more complex with that
so let's suppose we want a match
to the characters which surround this
thing that we're feeding it
so this is easiest to see with an
example
so we've got this dot e thing
so in the first element here
it's going to give us back the ke
highlighted
so the e and then the character before
it
next up subscribe there's a b before the
e
the b e gets highlighted and then the m
e
for the m before the e gets highlighted
i did a dot
dot dot e next so we're going to get
the three characters before this e three
characters before this e
three characters before this e and then
the dot
e dot that's just gonna give us back uh
the m e n around uh comment
here so that's just for generating views
however if you use the str underscore uh
detect function
you can return a boolean so true or
false for whether
uh whatever pattern that you feed it is
going to come back
so for even more shameless plugs if we
uh
pass the c as an argument to it here it
comes back
false true false if we look over here at
what we had for even more shameless
plugs
there's no c here there is a c here
that's why that came back true
again it's case sensitive so comment is
going to return
uh false for this match of a c however
as i'm sure you already know by now we
can do much much more than just looking
for whether
uh some letter exists or not so the
first thing i'm going to show you are
anchors
that is the first or last characters
now these are denoted by uh this
character sign for the first character
and a dollar sign at the end for the
last character respectively
so what does that mean exactly so
in this context here where i passed
carrot s
that's going to return a true if that
string begins with an uppercase
s similarly uh this
this function at the end here where
we've got the e dollar sign
is going to be true if the string ends
with an e
lowercase e that is false otherwise
let's run that
and we've got false true false we got
the true in the case of the
subscribe and for the e dollar sign we
got true and true
for uh like and subscribe respectively
now we've also got this str uh count
function
that's going to help us count
occurrences of uh characters
so if we want to count the number of m's
for instance
uh the comment word has two m's in it so
that's why
two comes back obviously you can use
this with a variety of other patterns
so those of you familiar with regular
expressions are already familiar with
this kind of logic but for instance if
we have
uh backs backslash d
we can match to digits if we have
backslash s
we can match to white spaces if we have
in brackets abc we can match to a
b or c now if we have the carrot on the
inside of the brackets
that's like an inverse operator that is
it's going to match to anything
except a b or c now that's different
from the anchor operator
which is on the outside of brackets but
then if we have brackets
a uh vertical line b that's going to
match to a
or b so obviously let's look at some
examples of this
so in string r there's this built-in
vector called
words it's just a bunch of to my
knowledge fairly random words
and we're going to create a table just
called df
and we're going to create a new vector
in it which is just called word
now let's see a few examples with
regular expression matches
i'm going to pull up the result here and
just talk through what exactly is going
on here
so in each of these words i want to
return the number of vowels
the number of consonants and the number
of times that we have the letter
a or c now for vowels
i can just do this by using the str
count function
and it's the it's basically just the
number of times in that word
that we have an instance of a e i o or u
so let's just see we got an a there's
one vowel it's the letter a
in a ball we have a or e that gives us a
count of two
etcetera etcetera for consonants
that's pretty straightforward all we
have to do is put that
uh carrot sign at the beginning of the
brackets here
so we want the count of the letters that
are not
a e i o or u now this is pretty easy to
uh verify this gave us what we want
in able we have b or l that's two
about gives us uh the b and the t
that's two consonants and then if we
just want the number of a or
c we can just do str count up for our
word
a um or uh vertical line
c and we've got a has one a or c
able has one a or c i think you guys get
the idea
so just for some more examples again
keep in mind
uh if we have the carrot on outside of a
bracket
that's used as an anchor so i'm gonna
use it here in a uh an example of
returning the words that start with y
so we've got year yes yesterday only six
of these words
so alternatively though let's use
uh the the carrot on the outside of the
brackets
and no carrot on the uh on the inside
what that's going to have the effect of
doing
is returning words that start with
vowels
so we've got a bunch of words that start
with a
that's the first letter of the alphabet
but if we skip to the end here
we see that we've got words that end
with the letter u so
you can trust me that this one works and
now
let's suppose though we want to return
words that do not contain vowels
what we could do here is just and
there's there's a number of ways that
you could go about doing it
but this should be fairly intuitive we
can put a
exclamation point just to have an
inverse operator
for str detect in the word
uh a e i o or u and look at that
there are no vowels in this in in any of
these words
so these are just some examples
obviously regular expressions
text mining all this kind of stuff is a
huge
field and hopefully you get the idea
with string r that the possibilities
truly are
endless and it's and it's an incredibly
powerful tool that's
really really going to help you out for
anything pertaining to
texts and character strings now that
covers what i'm going to walk through
here in this tutorial
like i say in all my tutorials for these
tiny first packages
this is not a comprehensive tutorial
there are
tons of different string r functions
and as usual just get used to in your
console here
if you type question mark
str underscore you're going to get a
list of all these different functions
you can look up the help documentation
for them just see how they work
look at the different arguments for them
and just get familiar with some of the
other functions that are out there but i
think for a lot of people
this should cover some of the core
essentials at least
it covers the functions i use the most
from day to day whenever i work with
strings
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it
please consider sharing it then as usual
smash the like button
and i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data